welcome back a nasty custody battle is
at the center of an unusual death of a
New York mother Michelle Knight Rider a
mother of three was found dead in her
home from an apparent suicide it
happened back in August of 2017 but an
upstate New York District Attorney
investigator whether Michelle's former
husband Lloyd could have convinced her
daughter to help murder her mom Erin
Moriarty reports this week for 48 hours
on August 28th 2017 police in upstate
corn in New York were called to the home
of Michelle Knight Rider police found
the 46 year old mother of three hanging
from a rope an apparent suicide but
Police Chief Jeff Spaulding had doubts
because you couldn't figure out how she
got a mark here no I didn't I didn't
like that that was unsettling it
appeared as though somebody pulled back
and down and caused that those who knew
Michelle best were convinced she was
murdered and Michelle's mom Jeannie was
even sure of the killer I'm thinking
it's more than likely Lloyd killed her
Lloyd Nightrider was Michelle's
ex-husband for five years the couple had
been embroiled in bitter custody battles
Michelle accused Lord of turning their
daughters against her Susan Bechet Omer
was Michelle's attorney
there were 26 separate sets of filings
post divorce and how unusual is that is
super unusual if you have two or three
it's a lot to have 26 is astounding on
the day police found Michelle the
couple's middle daughter 19 year old
Carrie at College in Rochester called
Corning police and spoke with lieutenant
Jeff Eberle
all right that's okay Kerry told
investigators that over the weekend
her father Lloyd helped her move into
her college apartment and that he had
spent all night at this hotel but when
police checked the hotel video they
actually see Lloyd getting into Kerry's
car and not returning until early the
next morning we don't see Lloyd all
night long
here it is 6:30 in the morning and here
he comes on to the camera he still
appears to be wearing the same clothes
that he had on the night before police
soon begin listening in on phone calls
between father and daughter and what
they hear makes them even more
suspicious meet you if Lloyd did kill
Michelle did he somehow convince Carrie
to help him you think she was framed I
really think she was brainwashed
brainwash Aaron joins us now here on set
what do you mean by that question well
I've gotta tell you this was a new one
for me there's actually a name for it
it's called parental alienation and it's
more than bad-mouthing a kid a parent to
the child it is actually a campaign over
time we are actually reprogramming the
way your child feels so one parent does
it to the other parent and really kind
of reprograms a child to devalue that
other parents take a jury buys that
though well you know what at first I
thought juries I could believe it but
jurors are normal people who go through
divorces and the American Bar
Association publishes study that showed
that out of a thousand families going to
the divorce where child custody was an
issue sixty-five percent had gone
through parental alienation so I think
if it was presented properly a jury
might say oh my god this happened to me
what's hard to believe is that you could
see a child disliking or devaluing the
other parent but getting involved in a
murder
that's you'll see it in this hour Oh see
I'm hooked DVR set okay thank you